if pain is more real than anything else
what's even more real than pain is
whatever we have to fight off the pain
and that's free speech
it's identical with freedom of thought
it's associated with this capacity and
necessity to listen deeply they're flip
sides of the same coin to use a terrible
cliche and all the clinical data we have
including the more stringently
researched research oriented
clinical inquiry indicates quite clearly
that the ex the exchange of information
like that the generation of of of
semantic and emotional information in a
state of relative freedom the revelation
of those thoughts and then the
discursive analysis of those thoughts
say and then the implementation into
action and the testing of them that is
the pathway to health insofar as that
can be attained by say psychological or
spiritual means
and so that's why free speech is not
just another
freedom or right among many
it's certainly not
viewpoint diversity or anything like
that it's the it's the mechanism by
which we generate the conceptions that
allow us to organize our experience in
the world it's that mechanism and more
than that it's the mechanism that allows
us to
reformulate and criticize those
conceptions when they become outdated
and sterile to dissolve them into a
chaos that we have to contend with while
it's occurring and then to reanimate
them in a new form so that we can move
into the future
[Music]
it's wonderful to be here this is such a
remarkable place for a canadian in
particular with our rather uh
what would you say paucity of history
it's really something to come here and
see a place that's so saturated with i
would say beauty and integrity
i hope you know what you have and that
you take careful care of it because it
certainly deserves it
i'm going to speak tonight as a
clinician
i would say
about free speech
dr orr
gave a bit of an account of the battle
behind the scene so to speak that took
place so that i could come here and talk
and uh
that's much appreciated a lot of people
put a lot on the line to make this
possible
but i find the debate itself somewhat of
a mystery i can't really understand why
it's
raging precisely the way it is raging
and i would say that specifically from a
clinical perspective
um
i'm going to tell you a little bit about
a clinician named carl rogers and i
learned something i i've
studied
the people i regard as the great
clinicians in some detail and learned a
lot from all of them regardless of their
particular school of psychotherapeutic
endeavor let's say or their historical
background or their genre i learned a
lot from freud in the psychoanalysis
from carl jung from
rogers who is a humanist from maslow who
was perhaps equally outstanding as a
humanist psychologist the existential
psychologists and the cognitive
behavioral types who were much more cut
and dried let's say in their approach
than you know the more uh mythologically
oriented narrative oriented
psychoanalysts they all had something to
teach me and and and i learned it with
great uh what would you say
um
it
i was driven by a great need to learn
what they had to say and thank god for
that since they were clinicians you'd
hope that reading what they wrote would
be helpful and it certainly was helpful
to me personally
practically in the conduct of my
profession but then also in my
interpersonal relationships unbelievably
helpful and i would say
the most stellar piece of advice that i
ever encountered that was actually both
i would say profound in some sense but
also immediately practical came from
carl rogers and carl rogers did an awful
lot of clinical research into clinical
efficacy as well as being a rather
admirable theorists now his background
is somewhat germane he was he was really
an evangelical protestant up until the
time he became a young man he was going
to go to china as a missionary
and stalk because of his developing
agnosticism and then i would say atheism
as a consequence of his inability to
reconcile the distinction between
science and religion but his clinical
thinking is saturated with
judeo-christian suppositions
and foremost upon them i would say would
be something like respect for the word
in capital as a capital uh a capitalized
phrase respect for the divine word let's
say but in a secularized fashion
but roger was also extraordinarily uh
careful i would say to elaborate beyond
the word to the act of the exchange of
words let's say because for anyone to
speak in some sense you need a listener
and what that means is that if you're
going to be a participant in a good
conversation or we might even say a
therapeutic conversation that not only
do you have to be an active speaker but
you have to be
to use a terribly cliched phrase an
active listener and it stays a cliche
unless you understand what it means but
if you understand what it means then it
can stop being a cliche and i can tell
you that if you take nothing else from
this lecture but you practice this it
will completely transform the way that
you interact with people and and that's
something that's worth noting too that
something like this can in fact
completely transform the way that you
interact with people and that it's
actually something in some sense that's
simple enough to learn in a very short
period of time
so rogers said that he had noted in his
interactions with people and in the
clinical domain that it was very
difficult for people to listen and that
most people had never really been
listened to at all or that many had not
never been listened to at all never
really attended to properly let's say by
their parents during their course of
development never had a mentor or a
teacher who really attended to them and
listened and
and rogers also noted that you
listening maybe thinking that that's not
true of you let's say as a person you
had people who guided you or as a
listener you're perfectly good at it and
he would say no
probably not
and so he paused a little experiment
that you could run and i would highly
recommend that you run this experiment
every time you talk to people for the
rest of your life
because it really works
and
and it points to something deep that
we'll go into after the the description
of the practicalities so roger said
it was an axiom of his
theoretical stance let's say and derived
it in no small part from the freudian
revelations i mean freud
basically what freud did in his clinical
practice was have people come into his
office his clinic lay down on a couch
with him not visible
and talk
and the instruction was say anything
that comes to mind anything and
everything that comes to mind so
completely entrap untrammeled revelatory
thought
now freud's observation was that if you
let people do that and maintain an
active listening environment even though
you were hidden he didn't want you to be
dissuaded or persuaded in your
utterances by any reflection of emotion
on his face that you would just have the
opportunity to
wander haphazardly through your field of
thought
and what freud came to realize was that
the haphazard nature of that tended to
transform rather quickly into something
that was much more coherent and
much less contaminated with excess
emotion and so that if you just let the
revelatory process of free speech occur
that that in itself was therapeutic and
you and that was a that was a uh a
radical claim for its time but in some
sense it's not that radical at all
unless you think that
speech is divorced entirely from thought
which
it certainly is not although thought
cannot be reduced merely to speech
because there are forms of thought that
are immogistic let's say but certainly
much of what goes on in the theaters of
our imagination that constitutes thought
is in the form of speech you could say
well we think with speech and thought is
in many ways internalized speech and so
the notion that allowing yourself to
notice what you actually think about
things by talking about them might be
good for you if thought is in some
important sense linked to well
your bodily incarnation let's say and if
it's not well then what good is it
and so technically speaking
the part of the brain that produces
semantic content the prefrontal cortex
usually in the left but it depends to
some degree on lateralization and
handedness we don't have to get into
that
the
the prefrontal cortex grew out of the
motor cortex in the course of
evolutionary history and so what happens
in the theater of thought is that
potential actions and perceptions are
tried out for potential utility so
they're revealed in a sense and then
potentially criticized out of existence
before you implement them stupidly in
behavior and die
and i believe it was alfred north
whitehead said the purpose of thought is
to let our thoughts die instead of us
which is
correct right it's correct biologically
it's correct technically it's correct
philosophically and it's worth thinking
about so
well freud let people reveal themselves
to themselves now later investigations
particularly by james pennebaker showed
that the freudian transformation in so
far as it did occur say in relationship
to trauma was not a consequence of
emotional catharsis which was freud's
part of freud's essential hypothesis
although he was more sophisticated than
that but actually a consequence of the
cognitive reconstruction and reappraisal
that occurred attendant upon speech
related let's say to trauma to
revelatory speech related to trauma
now there are other ways of engaging in
such things um there's the pure
revelatory explication and so one of the
things you do do as a clinician you try
your best is so when someone would come
and see me well first they were very
tentative because who the hell wants to
go see a clinical psychologist right i
mean you only do such a thing if you're
driven to desperation in some sense you
have to admit to yourself that you're no
longer capable of dealing with your own
affairs or that at least something could
be improved and you have to turn to a
relative outsider so it's not it's a
somewhat humiliating initial endeavor
and i i would say if you ever know
anyone who needs to be convinced to see
a psychologist because things have got
out of hand one way to smooth the way
forward to that is just to tell them to
try it once
right because then it's not a long-term
commitment i would tell people when they
walked in my office you know well we'll
see how this goes and i know you're
uncomfortable about being here and
disoriented and all that but um let's
try it out for one session and if it
works then you could have another one
and then you could decide again then and
so you know it's a gentle introduction
um
and uh
i would never assume to begin with that
i knew what was wrong with them
i was never striving for a diagnosis and
that was partly because i was trained
formerly trained as a cognitive
behavioral psychologist and cognitive
behavior psychologists are much more
concerned with particularities of
perception and behavior than with such
things as psychiatric diagnostic
categories and so it was a very
strategic approach and and one that was
really based on uh a gentle and
and facilitating inquisition it's like
well there must be something wrong in
your life i would presume because here
you are
or you're trying to make something that
isn't so good better that that's another
possibility i wouldn't presume to know
what that is because what do i know
about you
like nothing and so
a lot of the initial discussion was just
well what's wrong like as far as you can
tell how would you describe in as
detailed if fashion is possible what's
wrong and then
if things weren't wrong
well what might they look like so and
that's a great thing by the way if
you're ever arguing with someone in an
intimate relationship right because
there's some issue on the table and one
of the things you can ask them is well
what are your conditions for
satisfaction
like if this was resolved to your
satisfaction what is it that i would
have to offer what is it that would have
to change that i could actually
practically implement right now and one
way of doing that by the way is
sometimes the person wants you to say
something an apology maybe and you have
to be
agree that perhaps you should utter an
apology but you can say to them well
what word should i couch this apology in
that would be
sufficient as far as you're concerned
and they're going to say
well you have to figure that out on your
own or if you loved me you know and
that's like no
i'm stupid and i don't know what would
satisfy you and i'm awkward at these
sorts of things and i could use a hand
at practice and so maybe if you just let
me stumble through this apology in the
manner that you see fit
as as a genuine actor then maybe the
next time i do it i'd be a little better
at it but don't expect
satiating perfection first utterance
because you're not going to get it
because you're likely tangled up with
someone who's no more sophisticated or
intelligent than you are
so
so that's very helpful so
so
so the the the clinical sessions were as
free an exchange of information as i
could manage and one of the things i did
notice consistently in my clinical
practice was that if i really really
listened to the person
they were unbelievably interesting and
so i would say
this is rather
corrosive bit of self-reflection but if
you're bored in a conversation
you're the boring person
right because you're not listening
because if you were listening that
person is a strange creature man and if
they told you what you're they're
actually up to first of all it'd be a
shock to them that's for sure but if
they were telling you you would not be
bored and so there's a high probability
that you're sitting there thinking
what you already know about this person
what you're assuming by the way they're
dressed or the way they comport
themselves or their class or their
social status or their ethnicity or
whatever the hell it is stereotypes that
you're using as a replacement for the
genuine dialogue and then you're also
sitting there thinking about what you're
going to say next when they're talking
so that you can impress them and so on
and so forth and you're not doing the
kind of listening that rogers suggested
at all because you're treating the other
person as an end to
a priory defined instrumental means and
that's a big mistake
and so rogers thought you could check
yourself and here's the experiment and
this works in a lovely manner and
actually roger's work has been used in
uh conflict management
sociology and management at fairly high
levels of governmental intervention
especially in times of war
because it actually does make peace and
and it's it's so his rule was well first
of all you're going to be afraid to
listen
because if you listen to someone who
disagrees with you
and you really listen they're going to
tell you things that will reveal your
errors and make you change and now that
might be a good thing if you know that
you're so damn ignorant that a little
humility is in order and that the better
you could be given rise to in place of
the already totalitarian certainty you
know that constitutes you at the moment
but still it's especially if you're
dealing with someone who truly is
different than you the probability that
they'll reveal things in honest dialogue
that will shake you to the core is quite
high and that's very common experience
in clinical practice well partly why
else would it possibly work if that
wasn't the sort of thing that was
happening and so that was another
barrier to listening is you you don't
want the person to reveal themselves in
their complexity to some degree because
they shake you to the depths of your
core certainties and that's actually a
great thing unless you're already living
in paradise right because since you're
not the probability that you're existing
in error is fairly high and some of
those areas are probably pretty severe
but that doesn't mean it's a
particularly pleasant experience to have
them revealed or to stumble upon them
so roger suggested this technique so i
said i would get to the technique he
said
the next time you find yourself
embroiled in an argument with someone
that's contentious and uncomfortable say
institute the following rule
you don't get to respond to the person's
claims until they've exhausted that
particular claim and this does presume
to some degree that you're dealing with
a good faith actor even if they feel
differently than you do you don't get to
respond
until you have
recapitulated their viewpoint and
summarized it
in a manner they find acceptable
that's so
treacherously sneaky that
rule
because what it means is
you have to demonstrate that you
attended to what they say
closely enough and carefully enough
to first of all act out validation of
the idea that they have an opinion worth
attending to that's a big deal
people really like being paid attention
to there is nothing people like more
than that unless they have something to
hide and even then there's a part of
them that would rather have that paid
attention to than fail to pass
um what would you say
to go unnoticed every cynic is entirely
disappointed when his or her cynicism
goes unchallenged because there's a part
of them like a little unwarped part of
their soul that's still alive thinking
oh my god i hope someone calls me on all
my foolishness and cynicism because if
they don't that means that it's valid
and generally applicable and and i'm in
hell and what good is that
and so and i really mean that i really
mean that and so
so you're called upon to first of all
summarize what they said which is not an
easy thing right because it means you
have to sometimes it's somewhat
incoherent and emotional laden
especially if it's in the course of an
argument so you have to sort of strike
right to the quick it sounds to me
like this is the point you were making
and then you lay out the point and then
you see they have to be happy with your
summary they have to be pleased with it
which means that you're doing exactly
the opposite of straw manning the
argument quite the contrary and you're
doing them a favor in some sense by
reducing it to the gist because that's
actually an incredibly complex cognitive
operation i had one client who was
extraordinarily seriously affected and
in the final analysis i don't know if i
was of any help to her because
the
the pit of family pathology she was in
sconston was so deep that no matter how
far we dug there was already always a
number a new layer of lies underneath
the lies we had already worked months to
uncover it was just awful like homicidal
level awful literally terrible
but she told me
she went on a tangent
that lasted
for four consecutive day clinical
sessions like they weren't the whole day
but they were
50 minutes on four consecutive days i
had no idea where she was going she was
wandering all over in this freudian
associational manner and she came to the
point at the end of it it was
unbelievable she tied together this she
was very intelligent woman she tied
together this tremendously long
incoherent ramble into a little bow
right at the end like the punch line of
a remarkable joke and so
and she had extracted in some sense the
gist of what she was saying as a
consequence of the circumambulation the
wandering through all this territory and
when you listen to someone very very
carefully and especially if they express
themselves for a while and you say to
them well it sounds to me like this is
what you're saying what you're doing is
taking
a tremendous amount of emotionally laden
material a lot of it
unnecessary in the final analysis
because of the ensuing synthesis and
offering them a synthesis which is a
great thing to do
especially if they're happy to accept it
because that also means that you did
listen to them so you signified that
they were worth attending to and then
you listened to them enough to actually
understand what they were saying to try
to understand it and then you did
understand it and then they're way
happier with you even if you're arguing
with them because at least now they know
they can rely on you to be a reliable
listener and that you're not trying to
you know how it is when you're arguing
with someone there's a party that really
wants to win it's like i'm right
you're stupid and wrong and so the best
way for me to demonstrate that is to
warp and bend your argument and some
make it trivial in some way it isn't
especially if it's directed to some
degree it's like elucidating my
character flaw flaws and and to minimize
you in doing so and if you do that of
course well that's not a great road to
peace unless you're willing to bring a
big club to the argument and and many
people are and instead of listening and
trying to make peace and sort things out
they'll use all sorts of subtle forms of
suppression in their ensuing dialogue
just to keep everything you know under
the rug or in the closet i wouldn't
recommend that as a medium to long-term
strategy especially if you're trying to
bring peace to a household you have to
go through this horribly painful process
of listening to the people around you
tell you what they think of their lives
that if you do that then well maybe you
can all come to a place that is
characterized by something approximating
genuine peace and i would say that even
psychophysiologically you know i mean
when there's tension in a household in
multiple
what would you say systems of value
operating simultaneously there's a
tremendous confusion about what should
reign supreme right and you think well
nothing has to reign supreme we can all
have our diverse opinions it's
no you can't not if you're going to live
together in harmony there has to be some
overarching structure that unites you if
there i mean what what else is a family
if it's not an overarching structure
that unites you now within that there
can be tolerance and even appreciation
for necessary individual differences and
obviously there should be but that
doesn't mean there's a not a higher
unity that the entire
organization let's say is striving for
in some manner and not only striving for
but pining for or even dying for and i i
don't use those words lightly like the
absence of that incorporating higher
structures is a felt sense of
catastrophe on the part of the members
of the family they're always at each
other's throats they're interfering with
each other's goals they can't listen
they're in a chronic state of hyper
arousal because they don't know what to
do ever they're hopeless because no
goals have been clearly defined and we
experience almost all our hope in
relationship to defined goals so this
isn't some what would you say humanity's
myth or some some reality that isn't as
concrete as everything that you see
before you it's quite the contrary and
as far as rogers was concerned
well you had to let people talk
to find out what they thought
so they could find out what they thought
so they could move towards something so
they could move away from hell
because that's certainly what you see in
clinical practice i mean people are
suffering in ways you can hardly well
you can probably imagine because no
doubt many of you have either been there
or seen people who were there lived with
them you know to move away from that is
that's more real than anything else if
pain is more real than anything else
what's even more real than pain is
whatever we have to fight off the pain
and that's free speech
it's identical with freedom of thought
it's associated with this capacity and
necessity to listen deeply they're flip
sides of the same coin to use a terrible
cliche
and all the clinical data we have
including the more stringently
researched research oriented clinical
inquiry indicates quite clearly that the
ex the exchange of information like that
the generation of of of semantic and
emotional information in a state of
relative freedom the revelation of those
thoughts and then the discursive
analysis of those thoughts say and then
the implementation into action and the
testing of them that is the pathway to
health insofar as that can be attained
by say psychological or spiritual means
and so that's why free speech is not
just another
freedom or right among many
it's certainly not viewpoint diversity
or anything like that it's the it's the
mechanism by which we generate the
conceptions that allow us to organize
our experience in the world it's that
mechanism and more than that it's the
mechanism that allows us
to
reformulate and criticize those
conceptions when they become outdated
and sterile to dissolve them into a
chaos that we have to contend with while
it's occurring and then to reanimate
them in a new form so that we can move
into the future
and so if you're concerned with the
oppressed let's say why in the world
would you oppose free speech it's the
only thing the oppressed have
and if you don't understand that i would
say well that's either an ignorance
that's so deep that you should remediate
it as rapidly as possible or a
malevolence that's so appalling that you
should face it even though you'll face
it at your peril
and so you can't come to a university
like this that's been a bastion of free
speech in a country that's been a
bastion of free speech and a light unto
the world in that regard for
a thousand years and all do credit to
all of you for that
it's like don't forget this
this is the fundamental thing
say the entire judeo-christian
enterprise
to this date has been an attempt in some
sense to elevate to the highest place
the notion of the divine redemptive word
and there's no truth that's deeper than
that and that's that
so
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
you